one of the biggest myths about the
israel-palestine conflict is that it's
been going on for centuries all about
ancient religious hatreds in fact while
religion is involved conflicts mostly
about two groups of people who claim the
same land and it really only goes back
about a century to the early 1900's
around then the region along the eastern
Mediterranean we now call Israel
Palestine then under Ottoman rule for
centuries was religiously diverse
putting mostly muslims and christians
also a small number of Jews who live
generally in peace it was changing in
two important ways first more people in
the region were developing a sense of
being not just ethnic Arabs that
Palestinians a distinct national
identity at the same time not so far
away in Europe more Jews were joining a
movement called Zionism which said that
Judaism was not just a religion but a
nationality one that deserved a nation
of its own and after centuries of
persecution many believed a Jewish state
was their only way of safety and saw
their historic homeland in the Middle
East as their best hope for establishing
it in the first decades of the 20th
century tens of thousands of European
Jews moved there after World War one the
Ottoman Empire collapsed and British and
French empires carved up the Middle East
the British taking control of a region
it called the British Mandate for
Palestine at first the British allowed
Jewish emigration but as more Jews
arrived settling into farming
communities tension between Jews and
Arabs grew both sides committed acts of
violence and by the 1930s the British
began limiting Jewish emigration in
response Jewish militias formed to fight
both the local Arabs and to resist
British rule
then came the Holocaust leading many
more Jews to flee Europe for British
Palestine and galvanizing much of the
world in support of a Jewish state in
1947 as sectarian violence between Jews
and Arabs there grew the United Nations
approved a plan to divide British
Palestine into two separate states one
for Jews Israel and one for Arabs
Palestine city of Jerusalem where Jews
Muslims and Christians all have holy
sites was to become a special
international zone
the plan was meant to give Jews a state
to establish Palestinian independence
and to end the sectarian violence of the
British could no longer control the Jews
accepted the plan and they declared
independence as Israel but Arabs
throughout the region saw the UN plan as
just more European colonialism trying to
steal their land many of the Arab states
who had just recently won independence
themselves declared war on Israel in an
effort to establish a unified Arab
Palestine where all of British Palestine
had been the new State of Israel won the
war but in the process they pushed well
past their borders under the UN plan
taking the western half of Jerusalem and
much of the land that was to have been
part of Palestine they also expelled
huge numbers of Palestinians from their
homes creating a massive refugee
population whose descendants today
number about seven million at the end of
the war Israel controlled all of the
territory except for Gaza which Egypt
controlled and the West Bank name
because it's west of the Jordan River
which Jordan controlled this was the
beginning of the decades-long
arab-israeli conflict during this period
many Jews in Arab majority countries
fled or were expelled arriving in Israel
then something happened that transformed
the conflict in 1967 Israel and the
neighboring Arab states fought another
war when it ended Israel had seized the
Golan Heights from Syria the West Bank
from Jordan in both Gaza and the Sinai
Peninsula from Egypt Israel was now
occupying the Palestinian territories
including all of Jerusalem and it's holy
sites thus left Israel responsible for
governing the Palestinians a people that
had fought for decades in 1978 Israel
and Egypt signed the u.s. brokered Camp
David Accords shortly after that Israel
gave Sinai back to Egypt as part of the
peace treaty at the time this was hugely
controversial in the Arab world Gyptian
President Anwar Sadat was assassinated
in part because of outrage against it
but it marked the beginning of the end
of the wider arab-israeli conflict over
the next few decades the other Arab
states gradually made peace with Israel
even if they never assign formal peace
treaties
but Israel's military was still
occupying the Palestinian territories of
the West Bank and Gaza and this was when
the conflict became an
israeli-palestinian struggle the
Palestinian Liberation Organization
which had formed in this 1960s to seek a
Palestinian state fought against Israel
including through acts of terrorism
initially the PLO claimed all of what
had been British Palestine meaning it
wanted to end the State of Israel
entirely fighting between Israel and the
PLO went on for years even including a
1982 Israeli invasion of Lebanon the
group a stillness of the ceasefire in
southern Lebanon was shattered today by
the sound of guns bombs and planes the
PLO later said it would accept dividing
the land between Israel and Palestine
but the conflict continued as all of
this was happening something dramatic
was changing and the Israel occupied
Palestinian territories as Raley's were
moving in these people are called
settlers and they made their homes in
the West Bank in Gaza where the
Palestinians one of them or not some
move for religious reasons some because
they want to claim the land for Israel
some just because housing is cheap often
subsidized by the Israeli government
some settlements are cities with
thousands of people others are small
communities deep into the West Bank if
you've always felt a deep yearning for
Jerusalem
is a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity not
only to stand within its gates but also
to build the home of your dreams
settlers are followed by soldiers to
guard them the growing settlements
forced Palestinians off of their land
and divided communities short-term they
make the occupation much more painful
for Palestinians long term by dividing
up Palestinian land they make it much
more difficult for the Palestinians to
ever have an independent state today
there are several hundred thousand
settlers in occupied territory even
though the international community
considers them illegal by the late 1980s
Palestinian frustration exploded into
the Intifada which is the Arabic word
for uprising it began with mostly
protests and boycotts that soon became
violent Israel responded with heavy
force a couple hundred Israelis over a
thousand Palestinians died in the First
Intifada around the same time a group of
Palestinians in Gaza considered the PLO
to secular to compromise minded created
Hamas a violent extremist group
dedicated to Israel's destruction by the
early 1990s it's clear that Israelis and
Palestinians have to make peace the
leaders from both sides signed the Oslo
Accords this is meant to be the big
first step toward Israel maybe someday
withdrawing from the Palestinian
territories and allowing an independent
Palestine the Oslo Accords established
the Palestinian Authority allowing
Palestinians a little bit of freedom to
govern themselves in certain areas
hardliners on both sides opposed the
Oslo Accords members of Hamas launched
suicide bombings to try to sabotage the
process the Israeli right protest peace
talks with ralliers calling Prime
Minister Yitzhak Ravine a traitor and a
Nazi not long after ravine signs the
second round of Oslo Accords the
far-right Israeli shoots him to death in
Tel Aviv
this violence showed how extremists on
both sides can use violence to derail
peace keep a permanent conflict going as
they seek the other side's total
destruction that's a dynamic that's been
around ever since negotiations meant to
hammer out the final details on peace
dragged on for years and a big Camp
David summit in 2000 comes up empty
Palestinians come to believe peace isn't
coming rise up in a second intifada this
one much more violent than the first by
the time it wound down a few years later
about a thousand Israelis and 3,200
Palestinians had died the Second
Intifada really changes the conflict
Israelis become much more skeptical the
Palestinians will ever accept peace or
that it's even worth trying Israeli
politics shift right the country builds
walls and checkpoints to control
Palestinians movements they're not
really trying to solve the conflict
anymore
just to manage it the Palestinians are
left feeling like negotiating didn't
work and violence didn't work but
they're stuck under an ever-growing
occupation with no futures of people
that year Israel withdraws from Gaza
Hamas gains power but splits from the
Palestinian Authority in a shirt Civil
War dividing Gaza from the West Bank
Israel puts Gaza under suffocating
blockade and unemployment rises to 40%
this is the state of the conflict as we
know it today it's relatively new and
it's unbearable for Palestinians in the
West Bank more and more settlements are
smothering Palestinians often respond
with protests sometimes the violence the
most just went normal lives in Gaza
Hamas and other violent groups have
periodic wars with Israel
the fighting overwhelmingly kills
Palestinians including lots of civilians
in Israel itself most people have become
apathetic for the most part the
occupation keeps the conflict relatively
removed from their daily lives with
moments of brief but horrible violence
there's little political will for peace
no one really knows where the conflict
goes from here maybe a third intifada
maybe the Palestinian Authority
collapses but everyone agrees that
things as they are now can't last much
longer
Israel's occupation of the Palestinians
is too unstable to last and that unless
something dramatic changes whatever
comes next will be much worse
[Music]